hello my name is Jonathan Jacobs I'm the
director of Global Product Management
for Kaiser bioinformatics and today
we're going to be talking about the
analysis of human gut microbiomes and
antibiotic resistance with Kyon's
microbial in sites a our database in the
CLC genomics workbench
goals for today are first to show how to
detect antibiotic resistance genes and
their markers using multiple
bioinformatics methods and databases
including the new kaijin microbial
insights a our database determine the
taxonomic profile of shotgun metagenomic
samples build reproducible workflows for
routine analysis of your data and how to
use the CLC microbial genomics module to
identify potential mobile and microbial
resistance markers found and plasmids
and other mobile elements and lastly
will visualize all of this data against
reference genomes as well as against
assemblies from your own data
so as you know the issue of
antimicrobial resistance is becoming a
global crisis and we've seen a global
uptick in the number of resistant
pathogens worldwide and one of the best
ways to characterize antimicrobial
resistant bacterial pathogens is through
the use of whole genome sequencing and
well thought out and benchmarked
bioinformatics methods
the CLC genomics workbench and the
associated ELC microbial genomics module
which is produced by kyochon has been
identified as the top choice as far as
commercial software is concerned for
metagenomics solutions of clinical
microbiology and public health lab data
with the CLC genomics workbench you're
able to analyze a wide variety of
different data types beyond your
microbial data including human genomics
data other model system data including
RNA seek or structural variant variant
calling you can do routine analysis of
your sequence data using tools like
blast or primer design and cloning you
can do RNA structure prediction and map
your data on to 3d models as well as
proteins models as well you can also do
epigenetic data analysis including chip
seek bisulfate seek and other methods
and more importantly for this talk you
can use the CLC genomics workbench and
associated microbial genomics module for
a broad range of different applications
in the microwave genomic space including
taxonomic profiling metagenomic assembly
annotation and functional prediction of
genes from metagenomics datasets
antimicrobial resistance and very limbs
factor detection and characterization
and if you're working with isolates for
example in a public health setting or
environmental surveillance setting you
can also create reproducible pipelines
for assembly gene prediction comparative
genomics pathogen typing including mlst
snip page typing and camera-based trees
and as well AMR and Berlin's profiling
the kaijin microbial insight a our
database is the latest addition to a
growing ecosystem of capabilities within
the microbial genomics module that
includes a new database new tools to
characterize the vices and metagenomic
samples as well as a growing knowledge
base of commercially available data that
was previously proprietary which will be
made available to the research community
through our partnership with Ares
genetics
the new kaijin microbial incites AR
database is an integration of four of
the most popular publicly available
databases in particular the
comprehensive antimicrobial resistance
database from McMaster University
card read finder which is from DTU in
Denmark the Argonaut database and the
NIH is recently released AMR finder
database we compiled each of these
database together deduplicated the
results and reapplied a common ontology
across all of the data of making a
single fully integrated database for our
users to analyze their NGS data with we
also provide direct links out to PubMed
references for all the entries within
qmi AR so that you can kind of backtrack
to the original source of why a
particular marker or gene may have been
included in a our GUI AR to begin with
currently the qmi AR database includes a
little more than 3,800 unique peptide
markers for analysis of shotgun
metagenomic samples as well as over
5,800 unique gene sequences were used
with blast or diamond to detect the
presence of antimicrobial resistance
teams in assemblies from metagenomics or
isolates we pair this database up with a
series of tools including a snip base
point finding tool which uses the point
finder database as well as an algorithm
called shortbread for analysis of
unassembled reads from metagenomics data
and as i mentioned earlier you also can
leverage our nucleotide sequence
database with blasts or daimond all of
these tools are workflow enabled which
will enable labs to process hundreds of
samples in an identical way and promote
the reproducible use of scientific
research
a snapshot view of what you might see
opening up the QM ia our peptide marker
database we include the resistance
phenotypic and gene in the database as
well as live links which if clicked in
blue here it would actually take you to
bbi's website and you would be able to
explore additional details about the
antibiotic-resistant ontology data
associated with each marker we also
include an attribution to the source
database so that you can see where a
marker originated from as well as links
to the original pubmed references that
are supporting each of the entries into
this database
similarly with our nucleotide database
of gene sequences we provide information
on the Associated classification of
compounds that are the particular gene
drives resistance again and a phenotypic
classification indication as well as
links again out to the antibiotic
resistance ontology data or an external
website
and briefly the three algorithms that we
provide for use with QL iar include
blast point finder and shortbread and
these three algorithms expect different
input ranging from assembly assembled
contigs whole genomes or plasma
sequences to raw unassembled reads
obtained from either an isolate or a
metagenomic sample the output of these
tools includes annotation of genes in
your context sequences and the binning
of reads from the shortbread output so
you can then further map them back to
any reference sequences or assembly that
you may have to identify where these
particular read contains marker might
end up in your assembly and lastly with
point finder actually in the middle here
this also produces a gene variant table
for snip based analysis and predicted
amino acid change as well as read depth
and other coverage information that you
might typically expect to see for
example with oncology or aqua genomics
type data we apply this in the context
of bacterial resistance snip typing
so for the purposes of this talk will be
talking we'll be reviewing the data from
a recent publication from Marco candelas
group where they analyzed the stool
samples from 8pd a tricked patients that
went on underwent stem cell
transplantation half of these patients
developed a few graft-versus-host
disease symptoms and all the patients
that developed a GVHD
or characterized by an expansion of
their gut resist own
systems genes extended however beyond
the drug classifications that were used
during the therapeutic course but while
these patients were hospitalized and it
opened the question of you know what
what is the background with this tome
that these patients had and would it be
possible to predict adverse outcomes
from stem cell transplantation therapy
by looking at the gut microbiota patient
prior to their procedure so the data is
all publicly available at the NCBI bio
project archives at the link below and
it includes 32 whole genome whole
shotgun metagenomic samples from each of
the eight patients as well as the
associated metadata from it from the
individual patients and what we'll be
doing today is building a workflow which
at first glance this may look
complicated but we'll be stepping
through each of the parts of this
workflow individually and the goal of
the single workflow is to do both text
anomic profiling and AMR marker
identification in a assembly free
context and then also do a de novo
assembly gene finding annotation and
binning which then will allow us to
identify the specific context of
sequences and the associated genes that
have antimicrobial resistance markers
associated with them
you
so in the first case regarding the
detection of a.m. our markers directly
from reads the shortbread algorithm was
recently introduced into the PLC
microbial genomics module last year this
algorithm is an open-source algorithm
that was published a few years ago which
allows for the creation of peptide
marker sequences in a database which are
then used to rapidly screen
NGS sequencing reads without any
assembly and reads that match a
particular signature in the peptide
marker database are separated out and
can be classified as potentially
containing a marker related to the
database that was used in the original
short bread paper and in the context of
how it's used in the CLC genomics
workbench and microbial genomics module
we use a the qmi a our database to
develop a peptide signature marker
database which provides input into short
bread along with your own raw sequencing
reads of course
running this workflow is very simple it
requires three steps first you after
importing your data into CLC you would
typically trim and apply a QC step to
your data to remove any reads that are
for quality and then you would run the
identify resistance markers a short read
tool this tool then outputs a report
lists the antibiotic resistance genes of
interest that were contained in your
input data as well as a binning or
separation or partitioning if you will
of your inputs a SKU reads so you know
which reads actually contains the
markers that were detected and it also
produces a abundance table and
associated visualization similar to what
you might find in a whole genome whole
shotgun sequencing taxonomic profile for
those of you who have done 16s
metagenomics or other shotgun
metagenomics in the past you may
recognize this stat histogram is
familiar but instead of species level
identifications what we are looking at
here is the relative abundance of
different antibiotic resistance markers
that are present and each of the eight
patient samples each of the aged
patients across the 32 samples
and next slide
what we see here is that using our this
simple two-step workflow we were able to
identify all of the same resistance
markers that were identified by the
authors in the original publication what
you see here in this figure adapted from
the original publication but the data
presented is actually data from using
CLC genomics workbench with the
associated microwave genomics module and
we've exported data from our pipeline
and into Excel just simply to provide
some additional visualizations and
coloring of the results
we have the dates for the days post
operatives that the patients were given
antibiotic treatments and you can see
that in the red box we have patients
that were a DVD HD positives meaning
that they had an acute response to the
stem cell transplantation procedure
separated out from the patient that did
not and without any high level
clustering or other sophisticated
further sophisticated analyses you can
already see that there's a dramatic
increase in the intensity of colors on
the left hand side of the table person
the right-hand side of the table
indicating a overall higher prevalence
of antibiotic resistance genes in this
ending for patient versus the other four
patient that did not have an adverse
outcome following the procedure
furthermore the data on the far left
indicates the different resistance
classifications associated with the
individual markers identified by short
bread important thing for guests caveat
to keep in mind is that the short bread
algorithm does not identify genes it
identifies marker sequences or peptide
sequences that are contained within a
gene so individual marker sequence may
potentially be present in multiple genes
if it was a resistance gene that would
sound in multiple species for example
but nonetheless when you transpose this
data onto the data present in the
original publication we find a perfect
concordance with our results here with
those of the original authors
but resistance profiling alone is often
not enough and many times
researchers would like to also know not
just what the pathogens are bacterial
pathogens are doing in a particular
microbiome sample but also who are they
and what what are they
and so that takes us to the second step
for pipeline which is using a taxonomic
profiling tool which we prefer to as
taxpro for short within the scale field
genomics workbench so the economic
profile tool that we provide has been
previously benchmarked at being a
best-in-class solution for both 16s and
shotgun metagenomics Reed for the
purposes of this analysis we did not
optimize the underlying database we just
simply downloaded the default 16
gigabyte memory database from the CLC or
the Kaiser bioinformatics server through
the software and we ran a very simple
two-step tectonic profiling pipeline a
typical laptop for reference in case
you're wondering the typical amount of
time to do this analysis um on my laptop
was about 15 to 20 minutes per sample in
some cases it with a lot less the depth
of sequencing across these samples was
not equal some of them had two or three
times as many reads as others but
nonetheless we've designed the default
database to be able to run on a typical
laptop now we also have a larger
database that's available which mirrors
the pro genomes reference database and
users can also customize their own
databases using the tools within CLC to
fully characterize and maximize the
level of resolution that they may need
or individual project nonetheless for
this initial analysis again it's a
simple two-step workflow where after
importing to read and doing some simple
trimming
and quality control of removing
low-quality reads and so forth we then
apply the taxonomic profiling tool to
produce a variety of different
visualizations
in the lower right here you can see a
stacked bar chart and in contrast the
previous data that you saw for the
shortbread AMR profiling this chart is
what you might expect this is a list of
all of the different family level
classifications of organisms that were
present in the individual patient
samples across time memories patient
samples had more sampling than others
but nonetheless you can organize your
data as you see fit
next slide we see there are a number of
other additional visualizations that are
possible and in each of the time will
not be going over all of them but it's
important to know that for the purposes
of investigating potential AMR and
bacterial pathogen presence in a
microbiome sample a lot of these tools
are going to be key for individual
clinicians or researchers to know how to
use so on the left here you have a
sunburst plot of all of the data
aggregated for an individual patient
this particular patient had a very high
level of enteric alkis p.m. present and
detected in all of his samples and
indeed this particular species that was
president is microbiome also was
carrying a fairly large number of
antibiotic resistance genes which we can
see on a later slide
this sunburst plot on the left here is
fully interactive you can drill down or
back out as as you need to explore the
data at whatever resolution is
appropriate for your work
in taking multiple samples for example
32 samples that we analyzed with taxpro
we then can do some principle component
analysis in this particular example we
aggregated our results at the family
level we apply to break Curtiss distance
matrix and ran p coa on these samples
and you can see that there is a very
good separation of Ag hdhd positive
versus negative patient samples the vast
majority of the healthy samples are
clustering the center res the adverse
reaction and patient samples are serve
around the perimeter furthermore if you
wanted to investigate the level of
diversity across your samples which
sometimes is important for example if
you wanted to make a decision to
re-sequence a particular sample or try
to go deeper and get some additional
trace level detection you can visualize
across your samples with simple box
plots in this case for example we're
showing each of the individual patients
all eight of them and the individual
samples collected from them and the
level of alpha diversity present in each
of those samples as you can see that
we're fairly diverse
so furthermore we can take these same
reads that we looked at before from
shortbread bend them out and actually
run them as an animai crowby or
resistance input data set so in this
case we're still looking at species or
actually in this case we're looking at
family level taxonomic classification of
the reads but the input reads here
instead of being the total raw fescue
file from each patient sample it's just
those reads that are identified by
shortbread as containing a AMR marker of
some kind and in this way you can kind
of see the relative prevalence of a
microbial resistance markers identified
by shortbread across the various
different patient samples and this data
actually correlate very well with the
previous table I showed our heat map I
showed where you can see different
classifications of AMR genes in each of
the patient samples as well which is a
different different way of looking at
the data and what this gives you is the
ability to look at not just the narrow
your focus not just down to the the AMR
reads in particular but also to ask the
question of which potential
classifications of organisms are
actually carrying these reads so if we
wanted to look further into the data we
would we would know which species to
focus our attention on
so lastly we are coming to the longer
pipeline which involves assembly gene
annotation and binning of our assembled
context and then visualizing those
results in various ways this pipeline
actually does take a bit longer to run
altogether it's about 40 minutes or so
45 minutes or so on average on a laptop
my laptop and sealer and for this data
and the pipeline proceeds by first
trimming and cue seeing a reads as we
always do
using our de novo assembler that's
included with a micro a genomics module
which is tuned specifically for that
shotgun meta-genome examples by the way
we then once we produce our context out
of that assembly we then proceed with
gene finding and functional annotation
of those genes that were identified
using the qm I'd pay our database as
well as followed up with two steps of
binning and for those of you who aren't
familiar with pinning the idea here is
that you have completed a de novo
assembly and you want to ask the
question which species do these contexts
belong to or genus Azure family level
classifications can I make for the
individual content and if I can't
accurately classify an individual
content is there perhaps another way
that I could classify them or or bend
them based on other sequencing
characteristics like GC content Tetra
more frequency depth of coverage of the
actual reads etc and so in our workflow
we applied both ending approaches in
serial first-inning out-con tags that
have a high level of similarity to
reference genomes in our database the
default settings that we use are a 90
percent cutoff so in other words
individual contexts it can be present in
the X
a classification database at a 90% level
of identity or higher and then we also
because we use to databases one for
bacterial reference genomes and we have
a second database that we use for
plasmids which you can you can create
your own custom databases as well and
use them in at whatever combination you
would like any context that are not Bend
or classified using our techmount
thinning tool which is called the bin
can genomes by teknon imme tool we then
feed to the second tool which is the
thin pan genomes by sequence cool this
then looks at those sequence
characteristics that I mentioned before
and further tries to bend them in the
context appropriately and collect
similar context together so they can be
analyzed further
so just a quick visualization on the QC
and trimming reports that you might see
and also perhaps some of the reports you
might see from our Genoa assembler tool
so as I've mentioned several times now
it's always important to make sure that
you trim and QC reads and COC includes
all the typical reports that you might
expect to see including quality metrics
solve all of your reads across your
whole dataset the so-called phred score
and for the de novo assembly we
obviously report out the number of
contexts the average contact length and
50 value sort of their upper and lower
bounds for high and low quality contexts
within your assembly and a myriad of
other metrics which are all available to
be exported as PDFs graphic images or
Excel files yes we use if you like
Federer and later this year with our
next release we'll also be including the
ability to export all of the reports and
data analysis from CLC and JSON format
which will be is deployed interest of
folks that are building high-throughput
pipelines
furthermore
once you have an individual assembly
done you can dig into the individual
results and navigate through all of your
samples using our the CLC metadata tool
so within CLC you can associate metadata
with individual samples starting at the
individual raw reads and as you conduct
various levels of analysis and
subsequent analysis on that individual
sample then the subsequent results and
secondary files that get produced remain
associated with that original input
sample so what you're looking at here is
for patient number 15 a particular
sample which was day 41 post-op and the
original file name or fast you run
accession number is indicated on the far
left of the table on the top by opening
up our metadata table view for this
project and selecting that individual
file we're able to then find all the
associated data that has come from that
file in the window below and this peak
creates a very easy way to navigate all
of your results because once you start
doing text mount with profiling a.m. our
prediction denovo assembly etc you might
expect to find that you're going to have
a large number of samples that you would
need to keep track of and this provides
an easy way to do that
focusing on this individual sample as an
example
after we're done with our de novo
assembly of that sample we run our gene
finding tool and our functional
annotation tool which we includes three
different tools so the way that we
analyzed the functional annotations of
the assemblies for this for these
samples was for was using diamond which
is a very fast version of blast it's not
really the same as blast but it's a
close approximation of the way blast
works and the main advantage of the
diamond algorithm is that it's extremely
fast and you can provide it with a gene
database of your own design and use it
to annotate open reading frames CDF
sequences etc I'm sorry in a reference
genome or in this case a de novo
assemble no assemble genome in which the
genes were predicted so in our case
we've identified most eleven thousands
addicted c.d.s regions within the
assembly then did an annotation of that
gene prediction with diamond using the
qmi AR database that was released in May
and out of that it identified seven
hundred and eleven genes is high
similarity to known Anna microbial
resistance to that are present in the
PMI aar database are up six point sixty
five percent total I'll also note that
the underlying gene finding algorithm
that was used here was our own internal
tool which is based on the glimmer
algorithm however within CLC you also
have the option to use the meta-gene
mark and g mark pipeline which is a
secondary commercially available add-on
for PLC
so following the functional annotation
of all the context within this
particular patient sample we then bend
them and in this case this is a snapshot
of the top of the PDF report it's
produced by the bin pan genomes by
texana me tool in this case we were able
to successfully bin 524 of the 1,400 or
so con tags that were present in this
assembly and about half of those had a
high level of contact curity which is
our measurement of similarity to
reference genomes that are contained
within a taxonomy database that you that
you provide in this case again it was
the default 15 gigabase taxpro database
that we provide as an option to download
two of those bins included contexts that
were had a high similarity to plasmid
sequences that was based on because they
also included our plasmid database and
there's further statistics available in
the PDF from this taxonomy report but
more importantly though the individual
context now have been labelled and
annotated so that you know which bin
they belong to if there's a particular
organism or set of genes that are of
interest and we now have a way to search
through that list of genes and filter
out individual sets of contexts that
belong to a group of two at economic
binning group which you can then do
further and downstream analysis on for
those contexts that are not successfully
banned by the taxonomy to l-- we then
applied the bin pan genomes by sequence
tool which is based on a variation of
meta bat and another algorithm that was
put out by salzburg group some years ago
and this tool takes into consideration
read depth coverage sequence
characteristics such as GC content and
tetra frequencies and then makes a
prediction
- how likely it is it's multiple
contexts within your data set actually
belong in the same bin independent of
any reference database that you might
provide
so after we are completed with our
binning we then can take our context and
blast them using the find resistance
with nucleotide database another tool
that we provide within CLC this takes
contig contact data or individual gene
data and blasts it against whichever
nucleotide database you provide which in
this case we're providing qmi AR
identified 23 different genes associated
across these this particular assembly
for this particular sample and these are
genes that have been previously
associated with resistance and have been
annotated as such database again you can
see the table of results on the left
here shows a blast percent identity
score the actual bit score and the
length of the hits as well as the
predicted phenotype the compound class
associated with that gene and then there
are live links that user could click on
that we take them out to the antibiotic
resistance ecology site to get more
information most importantly this gives
you an idea of which contexts have very
highly qualified full gene sequences
contained within them that could
potentially be used as a lead to
identify and characterize those
organisms further in your data
once we've completed our binning
exercise the next step that I like to do
is take the original reads that were
used for the assembly as well as the
reads that were been separated out and
partitioned out by shortbread and map
them back to the assembly and then
visualize them within CLC in our track
viewer and this is a way where you can
add arbitrary layers of annotation and
other features including mutations and
whatnot and look at where the actual
kind of reads that are there are
containing these individual markers
might actually land in in your in your
assemblies and what you're seeing here
is a track to you where we have an
individual contact visualized across the
top we have predicted gene sequences or
CBS's coding sequences as an X row in
yellow we also have the total number of
reads
that were used to assemble this con take
in the first place and this is a fairly
short content of about maybe 15 KB or so
maybe 12 KB and the individual
shortbread reads and then mark on the
track below and they're also further
highlighted by this threshold track
which is a tool that we provide that
allows you to quickly identify regions
internet and assembly that have reads
and map above some threshold of interest
in this case I just set the minimum
threshold as a single read as minimum
you know is if you have a shortbread
read mapping somewhere within the
assembly I wanted to know and be able to
visualize where that is and what genes
were associated with that and in this
way you can then roll up to the gene
that is intersecting with where these
reads are mapping and actually identify
the specific gene that was found in this
context and this provides you with an
orthogonal way to identify potentially
antibiotic resistance conferring genes
that may have been missed by one of the
other methods that we already presented
earlier
so the nice thing is that all of these
different capabilities and tools can be
combined into a single workflow within
CLC and what you would do is build each
of these workflows up in separately and
then once you get them working you
combine them into a single large
workflow to do a whole range of
different analyses for you and this view
here of course is kind of a PowerPoint
graphic figure of what this work looks
like
but within CLC you can just simplify
view of what what a workflow might look
like and it's very easy to build these
workflows take just about a few minutes
to assemble and it's a matter of just
simply dragging and dropping individual
tools and algorithms from the toolbar
onto a canvas and then attaching outputs
of one algorithm into the inputs of
another and then configuring the
underlying parameters of each of those
algorithms if if you decided to
oftentimes the default values for our
algorithms suit the purposes of our
users quite well but you of course have
full flexibility and tuning the
individual parameters of each of these
tools as needed
and so beyond the context of the case
study that I presented we also have the
ability to present to analyze point
mutations so we have a tool called point
finder which is able to analyze reads
that are mapped or I'm sorry unassembled
reads that are associated with an
individual isolate for example if we
have a database for Salmonella there's
another for Klebsiella there's another
for tuberculosis MTD and these databases
include all of the snips values of those
the snips and other variants that are
associated with resistance as well as
the different compound classes and
resistance phenotypes associated with
those individuals Maps um the point
finder database is maintained by DTU in
Denmark and we provide a direct download
for our users within CLC to take
advantage of this excellent work that
that group is doing there and as a kind
of an example of how this might be
visualized this is data obtained from
Salmonella isolate that was part of a
multi drug-resistant outbreak of in
Pakistan and you can see reads here that
were identified by the point finder tool
mapping with a high level precision
directly over the point mutation in a
gyro a gene that confers resistance to
super fraction
more using the CLC tools in tandem
you're it's easy to identify large
chromosomal regions that harbor
transposons and other mobile elements
and once these resistance genes
cassettes are identified and you map
your reads onto them you can see in this
case this is a beta lactamase you can
see you know which genes are part of a
particular resistance chain cassette
then you can use that information for
your for future experiments and
similarly you can visualize these in a
relevant context and circularize your
results and the results you see here are
from analysis of predicted gene
sequences found at a plasmid sequence
the individual gene annotations were
obtained from a large database of
peptide and gene marker sequences and
the functional assignments were made
there and then we can again use this
data to then map our individual reads to
to see which which of these genes are
potentially highly prevalent in an
individual sample or you can even go one
step further and use this data as part
of a an RNA seek pipeline for example to
identify which genes might be actually
actively being expressed an individual
sample for a patient following treatment
of antibiotic
so
today we reviewed how to use the kind of
microbial insights a our database and at
CLC genomics workbench with the micro a
genomic module to detect anima Kroeger
resistance genes and markers from
clinical patient samples that were
publicly available we determined the
tectonic profile of these samples these
that were shut down metagenomic samples
we also discussed how to build
reproducible workflows for routine
analysis and we also learned a bit about
how to identify plasmid sequences and
also analyze mobile elements that might
be present in your samples lastly we
also looked at a different range of
different visualizations on how you
might want to see these markers in your
data and compare them across multiple
datasets long term
we also have a application no doubt
which is a PDF which is available where
we go more into detail on this topic in
particular this application it focuses
on the cell Mennella and Terrica
multi-part resistant caption outbreak
from Pakistan that I referred to earlier
and if you visit kaijin bioinformatics
calm and look under the microbial
genomics module resources page you will
find a link to this application note for
you to download and read at your leisure
furthermore if you have any questions
you can feel free to contact us by email
or telephone we have a one-day response
time if you contact our support team and
we also have a large number of
previously recorded webinars and other
training materials available both on our
website as well as on TV our kaijin bar
informatics com
with that I would like to thank you all
for your time and attention and please
don't hesitate to ask questions and let
us know how we can help you with your
antibiotic resistance genomics work in
the future